et si on pouvait témoigner de ce qui se
passe après la mort qu'est ce que tu
racontes
je voudrais que tu arrêtes le cas tu
l'as une minute et ensuite tu m'enlèves
[Musique]
t'as vu une lumière blanche
ça ressemblait plus à une sorte
d'énergie intense
on dirait que son cerveau a été
reprogrammé et je veux être le prochain
je suis la prochaine trois minutes génie
en a fait deux on a l'esprit de
compétition c'est un bon jour quoi
mourir c'était si bien que ça je suis à
dire y'a rien quitte à perturber je
crois que tu vois des choses
il faut arrêter immédiatement cette
expérience je pensais pas que les effets
secondaires allait apparaître une autre
hacker